hey everyone and welcome to another hd
tutorial and this one as you can see by
the title is going to be on how to
install themes in windows vista now this
is actually a relatively simple process
but this video is going to be a little
bit longer just because this video has
been requested by so many users so it's
got to be a pretty in-depth video you
know what i'm saying so first of all
we're going to open up any web browser
for this one i'm going to use um uh
apple's safari web browser and the first
place we go is www www.divintart.com
and it'll take us to this website right
here which offers us it's almost exactly
like crystalxp.net except they offer a
whole bunch of different um art
basically they have 3d art they have
animations and they have photography as
well as other photos but what i went to
was i scrolled down and actually i can
show you in this other tab here i went
to all categories customization then
skins and themes
once i got into skins and themes i
scrolled down and i actually went up
here to search and i searched windows 7
so now i found a windows 7 theme that i
want to install in windows vista here's
what i'm going to do i'm going to
click on it
and on the left hand side we'll see it
says download this is actually before
you download it you're going to want to
scroll down and make sure you see
everyone who has their comments to make
sure um it actually works so thanks
solve the problem very nice so things
like that perfect so i'm thinking this
is going to be a pretty reliable
download keep in mind i haven't actually
downloaded the scene yet so i'm going to
do is hit this download button right
here
this is a
preview.jpg so i'm going to see what
this actually does
actually it says right here download
from here so you click on that link and
it'll take you to a rapid share account
obviously we're a free user so we're
going to have to go through a little
delay
uh yes it has 30 seconds so i'll come
back to you guys when this is done
so here we go it says the rig right the
big bright download orb is right here
just click on the download orb and it
will begin your rar download this is a
winrar download here so here it comes up
with a little window just hit that open
button very simple and we see it's a 5.9
megabyte download a decent size because
it's skinning the entire windows vista
theme as well as a background and a few
different ui changes so i'm going to
come back to you guys when this is done
all right it says there's one second
remaining in my download so others i've
actually resumed the um here we go
here's the um the dot rarifier we're
just going to hit the open button for
this tutorial and here we're going to
see exactly
i'm going to hit close this is exactly
what it looks like when you've actually
finished downloading the theme so i'm
going to exit out of the web browser
here now that i have the theme
and now the next thing you need to know
is that we have to find where windows
list actually hides our themes here so
i've actually written it down we have to
go to start
my computer
and i'm going to open my computer here
because most people don't have that link
go on to local disk
go to windows
and then scroll down until you get to
the resources button click double click
on resources and double click on themes
now here's where we have i've already
tried a number of windows 7 themes
here's where we have the windows 7
themes all you have to do
right now
is click and drag that windows 7 theme
in
and right now it's dragging and copying
and we're going to hit continue now uic
is going to come up i don't know if you
actually saw that in camtasia studio 6
but that was uac telling me do i want to
cancel or allow and there we have
windows 7 so if i were to double click
on it this is the oh i wasn't supposed
to drag that sorry so i'm going to drag
it back
so here we go it is still in where i
originally got originally downloaded it
i'm going to double click on it and it's
going to tell me exactly my instructions
here to using this application so it
says press the install button to start
this exercise so we're going to choose
and a destination folder and as you can
see it is already by default selected
windows resources and themes so that is
very good just hits the installation
button
and allow
if usc comes up just hit allow and then
just go ahead and hit yes to all and it
would completely install that theme in
here so if i were to go back and back it
up and go back into themes the windows 7
theme is actually in here
so now we're going to exit out of both
actually i'm just going to minimize this
and i'm going to right click on my
desktop and personalize here's the part
where you actually apply the theme just
go right down to themes here you
probably already know this part this is
where you can change any theme in
windows vista and i'm going to see and
find
windows 7
40 by 900 is my resolution just click on
it and that's what it will look like
when i apply now i'm not actually going
to apply it but that is what it looks
like guys
and that is basically it so if you have
any other questions or any errors that
came up while you are attempting to
install a theme in windows vista just
see me and subscribe and send me a
message and i will get to it as soon as
i can and that is basically it so thanks
for watching this tutorial and there are
plenty more to come if you have any
other questions like i said send me a
personal message i'll do a video
response
or a video tutorial request so thanks
for watching guys peace